storm-ravaged Southeast Texas is reeling
from days of relentless rain and
dramatic flooding not seen since
hurricane Harvey remnants of tropical
storm Imelda
caused widespread devastation in the
region at least two deaths are blamed on
the storm crews performed more than a
thousand water rescues and the effort
continues a disaster has been declared
in 13 counties Imelda ranks among the
biggest rain makers in Texas history
some areas got upwards of 5 feet this
right now is a live look at Winnie Texas
where the water has overrun some
neighborhoods Janet shamlian is
reporting on the devastation just north
east of there in hard-hit Beaumont
tropical depression of Melda unleashed
its wrath on Southeast Texas battering
the region with pounding rain and flash
flooding the devastation reminiscent of
some of the worst storms in US history I
think it was a lot worse than like what
kind of the general public had
anticipated in Beaumont Coast Guard
helicopters airlifted patients to safety
one by one after they were caught in the
rising flood waters in Houston stranded
drivers and their children wearing life
vests were pulled to higher ground in
the fact that first car stranded and
people are getting high water rescue
that's never happened in our time -
we've lived here
even after happy man we gotta go even
Houston's police chief art acevedo
joined rescue teams waiting through
chest high water urging homeowners to
evacuate police and fire teams relied on
good hearted citizens helping others
escape danger this Proctor trailer
driver steered on to a flooded street
his truck cab filling with water up to
the windshield people nearby jumped on
top of the truck using a rope and hammer
to save the man's life until officers
could pull him to safety
there was a car over there in the Bayou
just north of Houston in the Alden area
high school football player Jaden Payne
jumped into a car to help save a woman
and her toddler after she drove her SUV
into a ditch with about 15 feet of water
you loser there were many many guardian
angels in this area over the last 36
hours volunteers stepping in when those
official resources were just too
overwhelmed this morning hundreds of
schools throughout this area are closed
today and it's a long way from business
as usual while the rains have slowed
there is more rain in the forecast for
today Michelle not good news Janet thank
you